Wagner are in the
permanent camps
in those camps where they were after
their withdrawal from the front line
for recovery for treatment rest and so
on
so there is normal rotation for such a
war
and after bhagmatar mosque they were
withdrawn to their camp where they are
today
as far
yes precaution
he
is in Saint Petersburg
where he is this morning maybe he went
to Moscow maybe somewhere else but he's
not on the territory of Belarus
Wagner is in this
peculiar situation and now I'm extending
my hand to them
this was
this decision was reached through
negotiations as you say with Wagner PMC
and this is where my decision was taken
I will stick by my decision
if I if I went back on my decision then
you would be wiping your feet on me
and that's number one second
I am absolutely not worried or concerned
by the fact that we will have a certain
number of these Fighters moreover
they will be deployed here under certain
conditions
and the main condition is that if we
need to deploy this unit to defend our
state
they will be deployed immediately
in any direction
and their experience will be in demand
in Belarus secondly
all their knowledge all their experience
that they gained on the front line
will be considered and will be ready to
use that experience to prepare the
military forces of Belarus